le département antenne réunion
il présente asocial
chaque année
4 millions de visiteurs
fréquentent les aires de
pique-niqué aménagées de
notre île leur entretien a
été assurée par le
département
pour limiter l'impact
environnemental des usagers
et protéger les espaces
naturels
la collectivité développe des
actions pour la réduction des
déchets sur site
elle s'engage aussi dans
l'entretien des sentiers
et la réhabilitation de sites
stratégiques
véritable atout touristique
pour la réunion
bon joueur présence de bluff
d'abord prendre une pause c'est
l'idée
c'est bien brandt
mais comme d'autres enfants
bakou
là c'est de pouvoir
six revers d'accueil de python
secte à la plaine des cafres le
traditionnel pique-niqué du
week-end est lancé
mais ce matin
les familles ont des invités
surprises
les gardes forestiers
départementaux sont en mission
de sensibilisation
le but c'est d'en relever
tous les poubelles du site et
sensibiliser des gens à ramener
leurs déchets chez eux
pour cela on a équipé tout le
site un peu partout sur l'île
notamment depuis 2013 sur les
sites à entre-temps fait ma fac
avec tous ces panneaux de façon
que les gens se sensibilisent
quevilly euro respectent un peu
la nature et emmènent leurs
déchets eux-mêmes
biodégradable chez eux pourquoi
les plats préférés
les bâtards côté plus belle
joker globale
comme quoi le problème
abadi a profité d'un peu de
l'homme noël
pour mieux faire passer le
message les équipes ont aussi
recours à des comptines ristic
objectif pour faire comprendre
les conséquences de la
pollution sur notre patrimoine
naturel les gens pensent
m les chiffres de graydon bob
gratton naturellement
malheureusement
alors dégradé mais cela
commence par là tant que c'est
encore notre devoir
il sert alors qu'à son rapport
mensuel
bon d'accord moi je dis jamais
que la policière on l'a fait
nous contacter par le procureur
la frappe mise à jour
le petit plan
en 2015 le département a
collecté 250 tonnes de déchets
sur les aires de pique-niques
près de 500 mille euros sont
déboursés chaque année pour
le ramassage des ordures et
l'entretien de ces sites
il faut savoir que le
département est propriétaire
de 90% du territoire forestier
et le département fait force
d'être éclairés
l'une d'elles dans cette action
une démarche de développement
durable
et de partager avec les
réunionnais et les bons gestes
à avoir pour moi préserver
notre territoire
des gestes qui rentre peu à peu
dans le quotidien des
pique-niqueurs
dans un rapport consacré au
concours sans repas amateurs de
notation
moi-même je suis un petit peu
sensibilisés pour la protection
des oiseaux dans la protection
des troupeaux
monde des animaux enfin
dernière info m endémique
donc je fais attention à anne
attirés vers
sur le site de la roche écrite
la préservation est une
question vitale pour l'un des
petits s'occupant de la forêt
personne n'a pas pour lutter
contre les rats
qui le premier fléau
le premier agent pas content
la population de culte
le tuit-tuit the pitt une
espèce endémique de l'île qui
est passé très près de
l'extinction il n'en restait
qu'une centaine concentré sur
cette zone
une fragilité écologique que
didier explique à ses clients
du jour des touristes
métropolitains aujourd'hui la
population alors là on note une
augmentation
et pour 100 m2 bellemare c'est
la lutte contre les rats
pour lutter contre ces
prédateurs les équipes
départementales ont installé
des poubelles spéciales au
niveau du gîte de la plaine des
chicots
une étape incontournable pour
les randonneurs
en revanche elle la corée
alors après que l'agencé
géologique depuis 36 ans il a
vu la structure évolué au fil
des ans
jusqu'à sa dernière innovation
l'an passé ça va me changer
l'ordre notre ami pour vivre
de forme
il y avait un campement devant
tout le temps
dans son dossier le club part du
niqab sur la voie royale toiture
vitrage
accessibilité aux personnes à
mobilité réduite les travaux
ont permis d'améliorer la
capacité d'accueil et le
confort cette oeuvre
mais on ne reçoit plus vous
pouvez pas vraiment au top
cette collaboration réussie
comme on le voit accorder à
tous les autres sont en cours
selon pour jobs
le peuple le plus important de
sa maman
une rencontre pourtant pour moi
quand même de belles
les clients maintenant comme
toujours le même je comprends
maintenant
la rénovation a été financée
par les départements le rock
eta
elle a été réalisée avec la
collaboration de l'eau nf les
acteurs publics et des
associations de protection de la
nature pour inspecter le site et
les cycles de reproduction du
tuit-tuit the
nous avons aussi rénové kadji
dans le cirque de mafate
mais bien droit après la
reconstruction du gîte de
bellevarde
je n'ai pas le temps et du piton
des neiges
ça fait partie de la
programmation
mais c'est vrai que c'est très
important pour le département
de reconnaître que les coins de
l'île font partie de la 5e
microrégion
quoi pourtant cette tournée ici
extraordinaire grâce à son
patrimoine
cette selon
elle doit être
préserver
warner bros
mais aussi de permettre le
développement touristique
tout en respectant
à l'actionnaire passant de la
trêve
l'équilibré mental affaire
c'est un job
à l'époque ça mais ça la
famille camara le voisin tout la
fac et ses munitions
dans la même case comme arnaud
siro et comment
comme chaque centre place par
e-mail créteil
mais à fait
on dénombre aujourd'hui 350
attaqué des villages sur l'île
elles sont fréquentés par 4
millions de visiteurs par an
chaque année
250 tonnes de déchets sont
ramassés sur site
pour réduire ces chiffres
le département supprime
progressivement les poubelles
il incite les visiteurs à
ramener leurs déchets
ils installent des
signalétiques de
sensibilisation sur les lieux
et mène régulièrement des
actions auprès du public
dans cette logique de
revalorisation du patrimoine les
geeks stratégique de
l'approché crif a été
rénové les gîtes du volcan et
du piton des neiges seront
également réhabilité
pour plus d'informations vous
pouvez vous rendre sur le site
du département
autre défi français gdf suez 4
en effet